[Applause]  now be careful they're very hot and  that's exactly what they should like  nice and crisp on the top briefly brown  on top and just let it rest for a couple  of minutes okay salad okay get rid of  these outside leads now flies that open  gently we think they're go good nice now  just like a rose right yes a little bit  of pepper prise it back together slowly  and just roll that round inside do you  want to punch him when he comes in  person now get the core and twist that  off  open it back up and sit it on to the  place and you've got this whole  beautifully dressed salad okay ready  before your guests okay right okay  from there get your knife cut the four  courses across and then scoop in that  delicious lasagna into the plates okay  now beautiful rich now the secret about  that I'm not dying is the most amazing  classic lasagna Al Forno done beautiful